so we're gonna do one of the famous
puzzles that you can play with a chess
board it's not chess itself but it's a
puzzle you can play the standard 8x8
chessboard and Queens so a queen if you
don't know a queen is the strongest it's
the best piece on a chess board because
it can move any number of squares to the
left and the right it can move any
number of squares up and down and you
can move to agony as well any number of
squares and oh if there's another piece
in its way it takes it haha gotcha right
so that's how our Queen moves diagonally
up and down left and right now the
puzzle is can you place eight queens on
a chess board so that none of the
Queen's can attack each other so all the
Queens are safe so this wouldn't work as
a placement because we've got one Queen
here I can take another there under
attack but maybe something like this
would work just fine now I've only got
two Queens here all Queens can take each
of the Queen so the colors don't matter
the question is can we place eight
Queens on the board
can we okay well how many ways can we
place eight Queens on the board first of
all how many ways are there to do that
let's look at that first right which
doesn't mean that we've got 56 blanks I
think we can do this calculation I think
even Brady can do this calculation how
many ways can you arrange 64 objects
Brady
yeah 64 factorial if you have 64 objects
there are 64 factorial ways to do that
which is 64 times 63 times 60 to 61 all
the way down to one so there are 64
objects eight Queens and 56 blanks but
you can rearrange their blanks between
themselves and it doesn't change the
position on the board so when I divide
by how many blanks there are 56
factorial ways to arrange the blanks so
we have to consider that the Queen's are
the same so I can move the Queens
between each other
I can commute the Queens between each
other and it doesn't affect the solution
the positions they are on the board so
for that reason we are also going to
divide through by 8 factorial there are
eight Queens and they can be swapped
around between each other tor divide
through by 8 factorial so the number of
ways you can arrange those 8 Queens
naively is four billion four hundred and
twenty six million 165 thousand three
hundred and sixty eight so there are
over four billion ways you can place
your eight Queens on the board but
that's naive Lee doing it that's not
considering how the Queens attack each
other so you're gonna get city solutions
like this one or this or this these are
no good these aren't solutions so how
many solutions are there out of that
four billion figure that do work so the
Queens don't attack what do you think it
is in fact only a small fraction of this
four billion there are ninety two
distinct solutions ninety two out of
four billion as a percentage is a tiny
unbelievably tiny so here is one of the
solutions you could place yeah Queen
here I put one here they don't attack
each other they're not on the same row
they're not in the same column they're
not in the same diagonal and put a queen
yeah again not in the same row column or
diagonal I could put one I think down
here one here and maybe I'll put one
here and here
and where's I put it yeah yeah I think I
got away with that so that would work no
Queens are attacking each other now
there are 92 distinct solutions that you
could have that includes rotating the
board and reflecting the board as well
so they're not all going to be really
different some of them are just turning
this 90 degrees that would count as a
solution now there are eight ways that
you could rotate the board and reflect
it for rotations and for reflections so
how many actual individual ways are our
letter to it there's 12 there's only 12
fundamentally different solutions 11 of
them have 8 reflections and rotations
pictures up to 88 one of them only has 4
reflect rotations and reflections
actually this one I drew this only has
four different solutions because if I
rotate it 180 its symmetric so that only
has four as half as many but the others
have eight so that's ninety two distinct
solutions twelve fundamentally different
ones so you can do this yeah you can do
this with other pieces can you place
eight nights on the board without
attacking each other I think that would
be quite easy could you place eight
bishops on the board without attacking
each other I think that's quite an easy
problem as well maybe or eight rooks so
they get I think these are easier
problems although how many ways you can
do it that's a much more interesting
question how many how many different
ways can you do it we'd like to thank
lynda.com for supporting this video
Linda is a great go-to resource for
learning about well all sorts of stuff
you can watch video courses and
tutorials put together by top experts in
all sorts of fields creative technology
business I use Lynda myself especially
for Photoshop any sort of trick or thing
I can't quite figure out how to do
Linda's always got a top tutorial that
teaches me how to do it funnily enough I
was just browsing the site this week and
found an amazing coincidence they have a
course called code clinics that happens
to use the 8 Queens problem it seems
this puzzle might be quite old but it's
a popular aid when teaching people about
computer programming so if you're a
coder why not check
on out now with over 3000 video courses
and 100,000 tutorials in the vault
Linda's a real treasure chest of skills
and information and you can sign up now
and get free access to all of it for 10
days by going to lynda.com slash
numberphile
that's ly NDA comm slash numberphile oh
and there's also a link in the video
description
our thanks to Linda for their support of
numberphile